so this this is not a there billion it
is a merger of equals but it's not one
plus one equals two the sum of the parts
of Heinz and Kraft will end up being
smaller than they are together right and
well that's certainly they're gonna be
able to extract a huge amount from
combining two companies they're claiming
this 1.5 billion number which is
enormous number by any standards the
question is how they get there and
they've offered some explanations so far
obviously they were kind of some very
obvious cost savings to do with you know
they have similar ingredients in their
products so they could get some supply
chain synergies there there's some sort
of more complicated synergies you know
can they put Kraft products into other
things 3G already owned so can they put
them into burgers the combined company
is going to be smaller than the sum of
the two parts because what 3G is going
to do is cut cost cut off the fat they
are gonna cut costs they are gonna cut
out fat they've already done a lot of
that at Heinz bear in mind so they
really I guess a lot of the fat will be
cut from Kraft
and what does that mean in reality that
means job losses we think there are
going to be a lot of job loss is this
number they're projecting I think it's
annually by 2017 huge number how do they
get their head cut production would be
the most obvious route is this a glimpse
into the future of Warren Buffett as the
Financial Times is writing this morning
that he is you know moving away from the
tradition of being a value investor now
he's getting into the business of
synergy and cost-cutting just behind 3G
right and as you said it's behind 3G
he's letting someone else kind of go in
and do the dirty work for him make the
cuts make the savings and is he doing
this because he can't find the value
targets anymore that's the question or
is it that 3G is just very very smart
they identify the targets they go to war
on they say hey you know what we want to
do this we want your name attached to it
will you provide the funding and we can
all come out and feel very well let's
look a little more broadly at what
private equity does the standard M
template is you make a purchase you make
a lot of cuts you lard it up with debt
and you make strategic changes what
seems to be different here is they're
just gonna make a lot of cuts right so
that's one difference is they make a lot
of cuts another clear difference is they
hold their companies for a long time so
3G don't do the traditional private what
do you think of go in as you say get it
up with a lot of debt and then flip it
they go in they make these substantial
cuts and they hold it and actually run
it as a highly efficient business and
then they find some of the wreck site I
mean in a way what they're doing with
Heinz is a form of exit because they're
reversing it into a public company
in making it public again but they're
still holding a stake so they're still
going to hold it you know in a way and a
large stake in a large company the other
thing that they do very differently and
this is almost unique to them is they do
these sort of deals one-to-one they're
not in auctions they approach companies
they get the deal done no one knows
about it until you know in this case the
night before and then they're done in
probably that's almost unheard of it's
really always competitive yeah